so I've been digging through apples
tutorial videos for developers about
Apple silicon max and I've came to the
conclusion that Apple's upcoming ARM
based backs will not have discrete GPUs
so the future apples silicon 16 inch
MacBook Pro and every iMac including
even the iMac pro will no longer have
dedicated graphics chips now don't get
me wrong
Apple is still planning on releasing
intel-based Macs over the next two years
but Mac's with Apple silicon chips will
not have discrete Chibueze the only Mac
that I'm not 100% certain about is the
Mac Pro because it's a high-end machine
for a very small market but I think I
know how Apple's gonna handle that and
I'll talk about it in just a minute so
let's get into the evidence that I found
that points to Apple ditching discrete
GPUs but first be sure to check out our
Apple product merch right below this
video in this developer video Gavin from
Apple mentioned that intel-based Macs
have a CPU a discrete GPU memory for
each of them and 82 chip on some Macs
now listen very closely to what he says
about Apple silicon Mac's
now the new Apple silica Macs combine
all these components into a single
system on a chip or SOC
yes you heard that right the CPU and GPU
together on one chip just like Apple is
doing with basically every other Apple
device but why would they do that here's
your answer
building everything into one chip gives
a system a unified memory architecture
this means that the GPU and CPU are
working over the same memory graphics
resources such as textures images and
geometry data can be shared between the
CPU and GPU efficiently with no overhead
as there's no need to copy data across a
PCIe bus so basically since everything
is built on one chip they can quickly
share memory resources and communicate
much quicker than if they were using a
discrete GPU which needs to copy data
over a PCI Express bus this is basically
saying that Apple
is preferring integrated graphics
instead of discrete graphics thanks to
higher efficiency in another developer
video apple mentions that their GPUs
will not have vram like traditional
graphics cards do they will instead use
on chip tile memory that communicates
with system memory that is shared with
the CPU I found an apple developer
article that again confirms that the GPU
and the CPU on Apple silicon share
memory which currently on intel-based
systems the GPU itself does not have
access to the system's RAM only the CPU
can manage the RAM if it decides to give
some to the GPU but with Apple silicon
Macs the GPU has direct access to the
system memory back to that same article
that I mentioned it says this don't
assume a discrete GPU means better
performance the integrated GPU in Apple
processors is optimized for
high-performance graphics tasks so
basically Apple believes that they're
integrated GPUs are going to be so
efficient and optimized that they'll no
longer require discrete GPUs now I've
heard a lot of people claiming that
Apple will not be able to match up to
the raw performance of other graphics
chips from AMD and NVIDIA but I'm here
to say that Apple doesn't have to if
they can pull off excellent efficiency
in optimization then they can match or
beat the real-world performance of other
discrete GPUs with less raw graphics
performance in fact some Apple systems
are already outperforming other high-end
graphics cards in real-world use thanks
to higher utilization and better
optimization and this is weird to see
considering the huge difference in raw
graphics performance and that's before
considering the new technologies that
Apple is bringing to their arm-based max
so let's discuss some of those of course
there's the unified memory architecture
which makes it much more efficient
Apple's GPUs are also designed to work
very efficiently to minimize system
bandwidth to reduce traffic so it
doesn't reach the maximum memory
they also support hidden surface removal
with the goal of only rendering the
pixels it needs to being more efficient
by eliminating unnecessary shading
Apple's GPUs also use the new TBD our
GPU architecture which allows you to do
shading lighting compositing and more
using just the GPU and it's dedicated
tile memory before finally accessing the
system memory which in turn reduces
memory bandwidth without this you can
see how many times it has to access the
system memory to get this complex
workflow done
so basically Apple's GPUs are focused on
being extremely efficient which improves
performance and since Apple is in
control of both the hardware and the
software they'll be able to make sure
everything is incredibly well optimized
with that will no longer have to deal
with Driver issues of new discreet
graphics chips like the whole issue with
the 16 inch macbook pro overheating and
getting loud when connected to an
external display and if you think about
it
Apple's iPhone 11 is still the most
powerful smartphone in the world and
that's only because Apple controls both
the hardware and the software so thanks
to all of that new Apple silicon
technology working together Apple could
get away with a single powerful arm chip
with both the CPU and the GPU integrated
without needing a dedicated graphics
I've watched every single Apple
Developer video that discusses Apple
silicon Macs and I didn't see any
mention at all of Apple using discreet
graphics so I'm confident that the
future Apple silicon 16 inch macbook pro
and every iMac will no longer use
dedicated graphics what I think is that
they'll first update the Mac's that
currently don't use discrete graphics
like the 13-inch MacBook Pro the MacBook
Air and the Mac Mini giving them extra
time to prepare before switching the
higher-end Mac's over to the Apple
silicon now what about the Mac Pro well
that's the main dilemma because it's
meant to be upgradable and it has a ton
of PCI Express ports for a reason so
let's get into how I think Apple will
handle the MacPro first off Apple
confirmed that they have intel-based
Macs in the pipeline right now and since
they mentioned a two-year transition
period they can technically release an
updated Intel based Mac Pro right before
the two years is over and then if they
wait another two years before updating
the Mac Pro again and finally giving it
an apple silicon processor they'll have
a total of four years of experience and
optimization with the new ARM based
chips before they announce how they'll
implement it into the Mac Pro this also
means that there will be four WWDC
events where they could potentially
announce new Apple made discrete GPUs
exclusively for the Mac Pro or maybe
they'll announce that they're keeping
support for AMD graphics cards since
they already have metal support built in
and since we already know that Apple is
continuing to support Thunderbolt it
would make sense for them to support
upgradable dedicated graphics on the mac
pro but for every other apple silicon
mac including the 16 inch macbook pro I
believe that we should expect Apple to
ditch discrete graphics if you disagree
with me go ahead and comment your
thoughts down below and be sure to check
out our new merch right below this video
and if you're confused about the
difference between Thunderbolt 4 and USB
for the different protocols check out
that video right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]